Hey guys,
stick around to the end of the video for
a behind the scenes look of what we got
cooking up for the future of wise crack.
Enjoy the show.
Hey,
wise crack jared here.
So just like everyone else with a ps
four,
I've been grinding my thumbs to nubs
playing God of war,
and if you haven't had the pleasure to
play it yet,
things are pretty different this time
around.
That's the thing.
Change the forest feels different.
Everything is different.
Do well on it.
Instead of a roid raging Greek god of
destruction who experience points,
Credo says,
now a melancholy dream daddy complete
with a child in a dead wife.
This stark changing credos got me
thinking,
is this part of a much larger
zeitgeisty?
See something is happening to our heroes
and if you don't believe me,
look no further than wolverine and Luke
Skywalker.
How to Wolverine?
Go from this colorful murder machine to
this angsty old man.
And how did luke go from this starry
eyed vendor keen to this disenchanted
recluse?
And in the same vein,
how did Credo Sco from this blade
swinging harbinger of death to this
bummed out widower?
Well,
to figure out why this is happening,
we're going to have to visit the era
defined by the king of swagger,
the Duke.
Welcome this wise crack addition on the
age of the post hero and stay frosty
guys.
Spoilers ahead.
Before the marvel industrial complex was
even a glimmer in Stanley's I,
there was another genre that dominated
film and an all too familiar way.
The Western,
according to theorist,
will ride all westerns are born from one
basic formulation,
the story of a loan stranger who rides
into a troubled town and cleans it up.
Winning the respect of the townsfolk and
the love of the school,
Barb.
The other plots are all built upon its
symbolic foundation.
Westerns from the likes of John Ford,
Clint Eastwood,
and Sergio Leone dominated the Hollywood
landscape for decades.
There was no need for iron man or
captain America when you had Clint
Eastwood being a bad ass and John Wayne
leaking Americana all over every set.
He walked on.
Young Fella,
if you're looking for trouble,
I'll accommodate you.
So what happened?
Where'd all the cowboys go?
Well,
Hollywood had a sort of western
backlash.
Instead of producing traditional
Westerns,
they started making a kind of anti
western or what were called post
westerns.
Whereas your traditional western wood
basket in the heroics of this gigantic,
much of a livermore post western would
show us this
slim gimme Gimme some water.
Please flip flip.
The basic idea is that post westerns
redeployed Western tropes to make new
arguments about the ideas that westerns
took for granted.
Now,
like anything else,
it's easier to show you how it works.
So let's take a look at a true classic
post Western unforgiven.
Unforgiven follows William Money,
a retired gunslinger who's legendary.
Talent for shooting was fueled by his
old friend whiskey.
I like whiskey done.
Unless there's anything else.
I ain't had a drop in over 10 years
now.
Sober and trying to live a peaceful
life.
Raising pigs.
William gets pulled back into the
gunslinger life to save his farm.
And family.
Unforgiven is a post western because it
takes the formulation of the western and
flips it.
The heroes aren't mysterious and hardly
clean anything up,
but rather bring chaos with them in a
quest for peace that isn't about a town
or ranch,
but about themselves and the future.
This structure of the hero leaving the
world of violence and mid behind only to
be pulled back in is exactly the
structure of you guessed it,
the god of war,
Logan and the last Jedi.
In fact,
they resemble the qualities of a post
western almost perfectly.
So let's start with God of war.
Credos left behind his violent past,
went to the woods to raise a family
after his wife dies,
dns on a tray and travel across the
realm.
Sue sprinkle her ashes from the tallest
peak so we can already see a retired
warrior looking for a calm life of
chopping down trees,
hunting and yelling at his son.
Look at me,
boy,
boy.
But of course nothing is easy and he
gets roped back in.
When bulger gets wind of his presence
and tries to hunt him in a tray is on
their journey similar to William Money,
who must drink whiskey to revert back to
the legendary murderer in order to save
the town and ensure his family safety.
Credo says forced to bust out the chaos
blades and revert to the death machine
we know and love in order to save a
trace immediately he's confronted by the
ghosts of his past and the reality that
he can't escape it.
You cannot change.
You will sound familiar.
Just like Credo slogan used to be a
turbo badass death dealer.
I mean his bones are covered in metal,
but wait,
who's that living in the desert like
some kind of weird hermit.
It's our boy wolverine,
but he's old and sad and has a daughter
now and goes by Logan,
your uh,
but we took you in.
You have logan imagines be wolverine as
a past.
His prime limo driver who takes care of
his elderly foster father in the first
few minutes of the film,
his aversion to violence has put on
display.
You don't want to do what's soon.
He's caught up protecting a young girl
from assassins cyborgs and other goons
like in God of war and unforgiven.
Logan is only drawn back into violence
by his desire to protect and help a
younger generation,
but despite his intentions,
the violence follows him and innocent
families.
Farm is turned into a slaughterhouse in
response.
Logan tries again to leave the violence
behind,
but it sneaks back into his life as
Laura and the other children are
captured and Logan's got to do some
savings.
Finally,
he comes to terms with the violence,
takes a serum like a certain whiskey
shot and goes hog wild.
He embraces the violence as the only way
to save Laura and finally finds peace
similar to unforgiven.
Not to mention Shane,
there's no going back,
right or wrong.
It's brand brand sticks,
logan and God of war.
Show us a former warrior turned
protector who must swap the shield for a
sword or a gun or clause or blades of
chaos,
despite the fact that all they want is
to leave that life behind a try over and
over to get away,
but they get pulled back.
In.
Test what I thought I was out credos
once a peaceful life for his son,
and that means war with the gods.
Logan wants to protect Laura.
That means releasing the beast.
Money wants to help his kids.
That means hunting down those who might
come after him.
It's the choice to confront their
painful nature for the sake of helping
others that ultimately redeemed credos,
logan and money.
So how does the last Jedi?
I fit into this.
It's not quite the same,
but just as those characters are forced
to Donna Mantle,
they've dreamt of leaving behind,
so to does space.
Hobo,
Luke Skywalker,
he isolates himself,
renounces his legend,
and even gives up using the force,
I suppose just as the Post Western
reevaluates the glory of the traditional
Western.
So too does the last jet.
I reevaluate the deeds of the jet I
order and the mess they've left the
galaxy in at the height of their powers.
They allowed God city cities to rise,
create the empire and wiped them out.
It was a jetta I master who's
responsible for the training and
creation of Darth vader,
but when the resistance is about to be
completely snuffed out,
Luke must stop fleeing from his past and
reignite the legend,
once again,
to sustain the light and save his sister
is ready to die because just like the
other characters,
he's giving something to the future.
The myth of scale.
So why is this happening to our heroes?
Well,
it all goes back to myths.
As Right said,
a myth is a communication from a society
to its members.
The social concepts and attitudes
determined by the history and
institutions of a society are
communicated to its members through its
myths.
Put simply,
myths are the stories society tells
itself about itself.
That's why we saw the posts western
emerge in the shadow of Watergate and
Vietnam.
We needed stories that reflected an age
of distrust in institutions and a lack
of belief in the American myth.
It's similar to where we ended up as a
culture after the 2008 financial crisis
and why suddenly we're seeing this
pattern reemerge all over the place.
We're even seeing this self critical
turn in the greatest mythic framework of
our time,
the superhero movie.
Think about the best marvel movies.
Winter soldier has captain America,
the poster boy for the American way
questioning the US government for not
just taking down the carriers.
Neck were taken down,
shields or learns,
a real leader has to confront their
nations ugly history and all the pain
that comes with that.
Tony Stark has space combat ptsd and
iron man three and in civil war.
The consequences of his actions come
back to haunt him.
Even Superman has issues figuring out
right and wrong,
which is the one thing superman is
supposed to know for sure.
None of our mythical figures are spared,
and this is what I mean by the age of
the post zero.
If Post westerns emerged as people tired
of the same myths from an era passed our
post heroes like Credos,
logan and Luke skywalker's signaling the
same,
and we're currently in the process of
questioning our cultural myths.
What kind of myths will we make to
replace them?
And what will these myths tell us about
the society we want to build?
Thanks for watching guys and thanks for
sticking around.
Things may look like business as usual
on the channel,
but we've actually been busting our ass
cooking up some awesome new pilots
behind the scenes,
so we're working on more shows about
movies,
a couple of shows about current events,
more about science and even a show about
the stock market.
So I'm going to give you guys a little
sneak peek as to what's in the works.
All right,
so first up we got to show that is
actually premiering in late June called
the film tourists where I go inside
cinema classics and break down the film
techniques that make them smart and
effective.
So where we usually talk about ideology,
philosophy in subtext here we're going
to be focusing more on the form and the
technique and how those things make the
films so darn good.
Yes,
there I am inhabiting the shot of the
wolf of Wall Street.
The next one we got up is called how did
we get here,
which is an animated series with a super
talented artists that I went to college
with.
Her name is tyler.
I'm so excited to be able to bring her
vision to the world.
This is going to be exploring current
events and the forces that shape them.
So this pilot episode is actually about
fake news and Fahrenheit 4:51,
the Ray Bradbury book.
Other thing we have going on is another
explainer series and it's more about
culture criticism in terms of real life
contemporary stuff.
So our first episode is called was the
Internet a mistake?
We're working with the amazing
illustrator of thug notes and I'm super
excited to be talking about current
events and talking about stuff that's
outside of media.
We're also working on new science shows,
so I'm sure you guys have seen our new
host,
Helen has been doing stuff like the
psychology of the purge and the
psychology of one punch man.
We've got more of those kinds of videos
in the works as well as Helen has been
working with a doctor at the University
of Southern California.
His name is Dr Jonas Kaplan and he is a
neuroscientist and he's actually giving
us access to a neuroscience imaging
machine and we actually want to do kind
of our own experiments to see if we can
draw conclusions about how the brain
reacts not only to media but to various
things that we experienced on social
media.
So this is kind of a dream come true for
me because I've always wanted wisecrack
to not only be about reflecting on
studies,
but being a part of the research and
studies process.
So we're also working on a money show.
So for those of you who listened to our
podcast,
show me the meaning.
You know,
Ryan Ryan has been our editor for the
last four years and he's going to try to
get quote stupid rich by investing in
stuff like cryptocurrencies,
penny stocks and possibly sex robots.
So learning about how to be good with
money through Ryan being crazy.
It's gonna.
Be Fun.
Also our pow,
Greg Edwards,
the Genius Behind Thug Notes,
Aka sparky suites,
Phd,
will be returning to wisecrack with a
new comedy podcasts that we're
developing together.
And you may have seen some awesome new
animations and graphics appearing around
the channel.
We're working with the really,
really talented Mike Perry.
So if you guys have ever seen broad
city,
the intro,
which was the interstitials between
commercials is designed by him and he's
looking to get wise cracking all new
look.
And we're really excited to be working
with him.
So get ready for more cool like that.
That's what we got in the works for you
guys.
If you want to see it early and see more
behind the scenes stuff,
I recommend checking out our
patrion@wisecrackplus.com.
Not only will you be the first to see
these things when they're done,
but you'll also get access to all of our
exclusive content.
So click here or click the link in the
description to go to wise crack
plus.com.
And by the way,
wisecrack is turning four years old on
Sunday.
So I'll be celebrating by watching twin
peaks season three for the fourth time.
Catchall next time.
Peace.